suppose that Erica simultaneously rolls
a six-sided die and a four-sided die let
a be the event that she rolls doubles
let me write this a be the event that
she rolls doubles and B be the event
that the four-sided die is a for use the
sample space of possible outcomes below
to answer each of the following
questions
fair enough what is probability of a the
probability that Erica rolls doubles
well over here we have our sample space
of possible outcomes each of these are
equally likely and so let's see how many
of them there are there are 1 2 3 4 by 1
2 3 4 5 6 so there are 24 possible
outcomes which makes sense there's 4
possible outcomes for the four-sided die
and six possible outcomes for the
six-sided die so you have a total of 24
equally likely outcomes so probability
of let me write it here so probability
of a probability of a is going to be the
fraction of the 24 equally likely
outcomes that involve event a that she
rolls doubles so let's think about that
this is she has rolled doubles 1 and a 1
they don't look the same but they're
both ones let's see we have a 2 and a 2
we have a 3 and a 3 and we have a 4 and
a 4 and it's impossible to have a 5 and
a 5 because the four-sided die only goes
up to 4 so there's four possibilities
for of the 24 equally likely
possibilities involve rolling doubles so
there's a 4 24th probability or if we
divide the numerator and denominator by
4 it is a 1/6 probability that Erica a
1/6 probability that Erica rolls doubles
what is probability of B the probability
that the four-sided die is a 4 so the
probability of B well once again there's
24 equally likely possibilities and how
many of them involve the four-sided die
being a 4
you have all of these right over here
involve a four-sided die being a four so
this is one two three four five six of
the 24 equally likely possibilities or
you could say one-fourth of the equally
likely possibilities or the probability
is the probability is one-fourth which
makes sense because probability of beat
it kind of ignores the six-sided die and
it just says well what's the probability
that the four sided dice four well
that's one out of the four possible
outcomes for that four sided die what is
the probability of a given B the
probability that Erica rolls doubles
given that the four sided die is a four
so let's just think about this a little
bit probability of a of a given that B
has happened given that B has happened
so essentially we are restricting our
equally likely possibilities now to the
situation where B has happened given B
means we're assuming that B has happened
so now we're restricting our sample
space of possible outcomes where B has
happened to this right over here
so now there are 1 2 3 4 5 6 equally
like six equally likely outcomes and how
many of them involve a happening well
this one right over here that we had
already we had already circled this is
the one out of the six equally likely
outcomes that involve that involve
doubles so there's a 1/6 probability now
that makes sense let me just write this
down this is 1 over 6 why does this make
sense because we the four-sided die
we're assuming is a 4 so it's
essentially this is analogous to saying
when you roll a 6-sided die what's the
probability that you get a 4 as well
because that's the only way you're going
to get a get doubles given that the
four-sided die is 4 and we see that
right over here the six-sided die has to
be a 4 as well in order for this to be
double because we're assuming where it's
given that B we're given a bavette B
we're restricting our sample space with
event B what is the probability of B
given a the probability the force
iodized forgiven that erica rolls
doubles so let's just think about that a
little bit
so the probability probability of B
given a B given given that a is true so
what's this going to be well we've
already restrict our sample space to the
to the essentially four equally out
likely outcomes that that a has happened
so where a is true I guess I could say
so there's one two three four and how
many of them involve event B being true
well the only one the only one of these
four that involve event B being true is
this one right over here where we've got
our doubles so there is a one one-fourth
probability that if we assume it given
that we've gotten doubles the
probability that the four sided die is a
four so this is a one-fourth probability
and that makes that make sense
if we've got doubles and one of them is
a four sided die we either have doubles
at one doubles at two doubles at three
or doubles at four you see that here
doubles one doubles two doubles three
doubles four well given that what's the
probability that the four sided die is
four well that means that's the one one
out of these four outcomes where it's
double for us right over here all right
what is the probability of a and B the
probability that Erika rolls doubles and
the second die is four so this means if
both a and B happened well let's look at
this let me write it here let me do it
in this we did a new color so the
probability of all right and here in a
neutral color probability of a and B
probability of a and B is equal to well
now we're looking at once again we have
24 equally likely outcomes we have 24
equally likely outcomes and how many of
them involve a and B well to get a and B
you have to have doubles and and the
4-sided die needs to be a four
essentially you have to have doubles
four well there's only one
out come out of the 24 equally likely
outcomes that meets that that meets that
situation this one right over here
so there is a 1/4 one sorry one
twenty-fourth probability so 1 over 24
what is probability of a get the times
probability of B given a well here we
could just go back to our numbers right
over here probability of a that's going
to be 1 over 6 let me do that in magenta
color I like to keep my colors be
careful about my colors that's 1/6 times
probability of B given a so probability
of B given a is 1/4 right over here
times 1/4 which is curious enough 124
124 what is probability of B times
probability of a given B well
probability of B we figured out is 1/4
1/4 and the probability of a given B is
1/6 times 1/6 times 1/6 which is equal
to which is equal to 124 now does it
make sense that the probability of a and
B is 124 the probability of a times
probability of B given a is 124 and the
probability of B times probability of a
given B they're all 124 is this always
going to be the case well sure think
about what probability of a and B means
well it means that they both happened
but that's the same way is saying well
what's the probability what's the
probability of let's just say a is
happening well now for B and a to happen
it's just going to be that times the
probability that B is true given that a
is true because we're you could kind of
say well we're already kind of
constraining it we're already
multiplying by the probability of a
being true and now we're multiplying by
the probability that B is true given a
is true actually often like to swap
these around just it gets a little bit
clearer in my head so this one let's
just write it like this the probability
of B given a time's the probability of a
so this is the probability that event a
is true and this is the probability that
B event B
is true given that we know that a is
true and it completely makes sense that
this is going to be the same thing as
the probability of a and B clearly this
is the probability of both of these both
a and B happening you can go the other
way around
the probability of a given B times the
probability of B that would also be so B
we're saying B needs to be true and that
given that B is true that a needs to be
true as well so it makes complete sense
that this is going to be the probability
of a and B as well